big news SEC officially approved 11
applications for Bitcoin ETFs and this
is a big deal because some people are
saying wait a minute it doesn't this
make this official Kathy Wood came out
saying I think Bitcoin is about to go to
a million and a half she's saying it may
30X what it is today many people are
losing their minds Black Rock Fidelity
Investments Arc Investments Invesco
Wisdom Tree bitwise Asset Management
Valkyrie grayscale are some of the
applications that are being submitted
now chair Gary Gensler comes out and by
the way Gary Gensler is L by the xrp
folks he's a sweetheart they just love
him they always send him nice love
letters but he comes out and says the
following he says a company in the
agency's approval of Bitcoin ETFs warned
that the funds approval shouldn't be
taken as an indication the agency is
backing off crypto enforcement here's
this quote today's action does not
approve or endorse crypto trading
platforms or intermediaries which for
the most part are non-compliant with the
Federal Security law and often have
conflict of interest so some may say
well isn't this kind of like if ETF
approves that these 11 applications
isn't this like one step closer for
regulation like that's exactly what Gary
wants no isn't he trying to find out
exactly what's going on with the money
there possibly we can talk about that as
well but here's the key the reason why
this is important when you look at all
the asset classes of different
Generations this is what you'll find
there's roughly 156 trillion dollars in
US assets and you can see the dark green
to the left is Boomers half of it Boomer
have Gen X has 30% of it silent
generation has 12% of it and Millennials
have 8 1 12% of it but on the baby
boomer side look at equities and mutual
funds how big is that $19
trillion can you imagine now these
company is reaching out to these Boomer
clients and saying hey you got all this
money how about we take some of your1
199 trillion and put a small percentage
of it in ETF what could that to to the
Bitcoin ETF who knows but we're going to
talk about all of that today so if you
get value out of the this video give it
a thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
so now if you're watching this you like
Pat the last thing you said is $19
trillion of the Boomer assets if they
take a small percentage of it what could
that do to bitcoin because currently
bitcoin's market cap is only around $800
billion so when Kathy Wood says 30X that
means 800 billion would be what $24
trillion maybe that's kind of crazy by
2030 I'll give you Elon musk's
prediction at the end as well but could
the 800 billion go to 8 trillion that's
10x could that happen maybe that's
something to think about and have people
already started putting money into the
ETFs they have here's what it's looking
like on their initial trading day
Thursday Bitcoin ETFs recorded inflows
exceeding $4.3 billion establishing an
unprecedented milestone for exchange
traded funds products black rock inks I
share Bitcoin trust ETF attracted over a
billion dollars and great skilles
Bitcoin trust experiened inflow
surpassing $2 billion the reason why
this is important is take a look at some
of the dates here and see what happened
on June 16th 2023 Black Rock filed for a
spot Bitcoin ETF they called it I shares
Bitcoin trust at the time Bitcoin was
trading at $225,500 but quickly shot up
Beyond $3,000 Bitcoin has gained roughly
63% since Black Rock filed its ETF
application and black rock names JP
Morgan as authorized participating for
spot Bitcoin ETF which means in a way JP
Morgan Chase and black rock is saying
Bitcoin is here to stay it's not going
anywhere however this can't all be good
right like you got to sit there and say
there's got to be something bad about
this doesn't hurt any aspect of Bitcoin
here's what Arthur Hayes had to say he's
the co-founder of bitmex he says Black
Rock will completely destroy Bitcoin now
why is that based on their direct and
indirect investment it is estimated that
BlackRock State Street and Vanguard
collectively own 1 and 2% of all Bitcoin
in circulation Hay's argument is that if
Black Rock which is in the asset
accumulation game vacuums up all the
Bitcoin there will be no more Bitcoin
transactions and those who secure the
Bitcoin Network in return for fees and
newly minted Bitcoin known as miners
would be unable to afford the energy it
cost to secure the network as a result
they would shut off their machines
without the miners the network dies and
Bitcoin vanishes so now why is he saying
this what's the big deal with miners
like what do you mean if they don't do
anything with it are miners that
important look how much Bitcoin devours
electricity more than many countries out
there when you look at this chart at the
top you'll see annual electricity
consumption in comparison China's number
one US is 2 Germany's three all the
world's data centers is for look what's
next Bitcoin more than Norway more than
Bangladesh more than Switzerland more
than Google more than Facebook it's more
than Google and Facebook combined times8
that's a lot of energy so his argument
comes back to how Bitcoin transactions
work to limit inflation Bitcoin coin
Creator designed Bitcoin to only have 21
million Bitcoins however Bitcoin only
exists If It Moves when a Bitcoin
transaction is made miners take the
information and apply a mathematical
formula verifying the transaction and
adding it to the blockchain this process
is known as proof of work it's called
that because the process of mining is
very hard and timec consuming requiring
large amounts of processing power and
time multiple confirmations other miners
verifying the blocks are typically
needed for transaction to be considered
secure as a reward for their services
miners are paid in Bitcoin for each new
block they add to the blockchain so now
there's a lot of predictions being made
about is this thing going to hit
$100,000 before the end of the year or
not there's one chart that shows it will
because of the history of what happens
to bitcoin when it goes through haling
let me kind of explain to you what this
means the size of Bitcoin block rewards
is Haled after the creation of every
210,000 blocks which takes around four
years at bitcoin's Inception in 2009
each block reward was worth 50 Bitcoins
in May 2020 the block reward was held a
third time to 6.25 Bitcoins in 2023
there were 19.4 million Bitcoins in
existence 92% of the total plan Supply
the block reward is scheduled to reach
zero around May of 2140 but mining will
likely no longer be profitable long
before that date is reached as of April
2039 about
99.6% of Bitcoins will already have been
issued and the block reward will be just
.19 95 3 1 2 5 0 Bitcoins so when you
look at this chart this is what you'll
notice first haling that took place
November 208 2012 Bitcoin was roughly
$12.22 now four years later July 9th of
2016 Bitcoin at the time that's the
second haling it was priced at
65761 then go back four years later
which is May of 2020 third haling
Bitcoin was worth $9,500 and in this
year the date they're looking at that's
going to have again is April 22nd of
2024 nobody knows what number it's
exactly going to be at but everyone's
guesstimating that number is going to be
higher and that's why some people are
speculating Bitcoin is going to hit
$100,000 this year and by the way
remember this is all just hypothetical
is what we're talking about I don't want
you to get off this stin here and go buy
Bitcoin and say well you know according
to this video that path did Bitcoin is
going to go no no I'm just giving you
data and trends for you to consider yes
Elam mus says it's going to go to a
million dollar yes Kathy Wood says it
goes to a million and a half but John
McAfee a few years ago said it was going
to go to $1,000 when it was at 9 and it
didn't happen so don't jump to
conclusion with all these different
predictions people are making it's just
look at the numbers and then see your
risk tolerance time Horizon make the
decision based on that here's another
one to consider Global liquidity if you
look at this chart what do you notice
the more liquid money that we have
worldwide look what happens to bitcoin
and this same applies to S&P it's not
like this is an epiphany moment of a
chart we're looking at this goes with
everything the more liquid assets liquid
money that's out there last but least to
compare the three gold Fiat which is a
US dollar in crypto this is the argument
that's made by the Bitcoin Community
fungible interchangeable high high high
non-consumable the same portability gold
moderate the rest high high durable High
Fiat moderate crypto High secure you see
moderate moderate High easily
transactable low gold high high scarce
moderate low high sovere government
issued low high low decentralized as of
today cuz if Gary Gensler has it his way
this may change low low high smart
programmable low low high and by the way
this is not a you know article written
by you know coinbase or something this
is Investopedia that puts something out
there for the average person to be
thinking about they're not leaning one
way or another they're just kind of
giving you the feedback so look I mean
obviously to me when a black rock and a
JP Morgan Chase is approving something
like this that's the closest thing to to
the US government given the okay that
you're doing this so what does that
really mean does that mean it's official
it's real the biggest critics that said
they would never ever do anything like
this now they're doing it what does that
do it means yes it means Boomers who
trust level and risk tolerance is
probably the lowest they don't trust
anything new they don't like any changes
they don't want to do anything that's
out of the ordinary now this gets to
Boomer who are the richest people 50%
who are like hey what do you think John
do at Goldman Sachs Morgan Stanley do
you may want to put 5% you may want to
put 3% of what of 19 trillion what's 5%
of 19 trillion it's a trillion dollars
what does that do instant double does
that what that means maybe again
everything I said is pure speculation
but I'm researching and looking at the
topic myself just like you are before
you make any crazy decision with your
money go do more research on on your own
talk to your adviser if it makes sense
then consider it but this is definitely
a very big event maybe one of the
biggest historic events that took place
with Bitcoin that's why the entire
industry is talking about this if you
got value out of this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
at the same time we did a video on
collapsing of the US dollar then we
studied currencies that we've had how
many currencies we've had worldwide like
World currencies and the cycle could
this be a change that's taking place
nobody knows but I suggest you go watch
that video very very interesting on
what's happened with the history of
currency take care everybody bye-bye
bye-bye
a